alexis est avec nous alexis on va voir
dans un instant la réaction du lycée
merci alexis d'être là alors alexis déjà
taxe était juste de faire tes pmp je
voudrais te remercier vraiment
énormément alors raconte-nous toi tu te
maquilles parce que sait-on qu'il sait
ton style c'est ça exactement
en gros ça a été vraiment une révélation
pour moi au début de l'année
bah il ya une amie qui a voulu faire un
produit à un projet d'art sur moi ouais
elle m'a maquiller et je me suis dit
waouh enfin moi ça me correspond et ça
tu te trouves mieux pas qui est tu te
trouves tu trouves que ça te va bien
oui je trouve que c'est beaucoup non
mais c'est vrai quoi tu te maquilles
juste les yeux
bah oui juste les yeux donc ça arrive tu
arrives à l'école tu arrives juste comme
ça c'est ça m'est arrivé c'est tout ce
que tu as tu sais tu es tout voilà c'est
fait pour ça oui c'est pour ça c'est
juste parce que tu as les yeux maquillés
et ça c'est un parent d'élève qui a
demandé qui a été choquée exactement en
gros mon lycée partage avec le collège
et le 29 bat on peut se croiser que les
collégiens mais bas selon sa fille elle
a été choquée de me voir en talons et
maquillés à l'entente allons aussi oui
mais quand je te dis talons c'est quoi
lassé des chaussures compensées mais ça
va soit c'est pour ça c'est pour ces
chaussures là non non pas du tout c'est
pour aider et bozétie messe debout de
bâton et moi je m'étais salaf y était
comme ça l'était chez marco de las vegas
voilà je mets ça voilà tu mets ça voilà
ouais ouais ça va oui c'est pas bien
talon aiguille ça ouais il arrive pas
voilà donc vous je voudrais d'abord voir
ce qu'ils ne sont pas choqués par la
décision du lycée vous auriez pris la
même décision
ben voilà il ya ça aussi et sa g
amy qu'une fois d'accord ça l'a tué en
dessous le reportage pour dire que oui
shana mais j'ai 3 me maquille voilà des
sortes et des talons exactement toi tu
dis tu dis voilà c'est mon style c'est
on kiffe
non mais ça alors l'établissement vous
vous êtes d'accord avec l'état mission
est ce que vous n'êtes pas choqué par la
décision
j'aimerais avoir l'avis de jean michel
méresse oui je suis pas choqué parce que
je pense que le lycée a pris cette
mesure pour protéger justement alexis
parce que le dis parce que les enfants
sont très cruels entre eux je pense que
ça crée plus de réactions hostiles
qu'autre chose et se protéger des
réactions hostiles qui ne manqueront pas
d'arriver
parce que ça peut être de maquillage
après il ya d'autres enfants qui peuvent
se dire moi aussi je ressens ce g7
sensibilité je peux venir en jupe aussi
moi je suis pour des contrées par un
uniforme pour les garçons comme ça pour
justement pompiers pas de disparité se
soient sociales sexuelles ou
intellectuelles pour qu'on soit tous au
même niveau et même chose de réussi
alors le lendemain ça le lendemain tu
dois te rappel à l'ordre
il ya beaucoup de camarades à vous qui
sont venus maquiller au lycée pour vous
soutenir
exactement tout le laissait quand je dis
vraiment tous les lycées c'est fou
second première finale vainqueurs sont
vraiment le monde était maquillée on a
un arrêt de bus devant le lycée est
vraiment faim là par exemple c'est un
exemple la rue booth était complet on a
vraiment maquiller tour donc ça
dérangeait pas les autres élèves ces
personnes ça dérangeait personne sont
strictement personne et personne n'a
jamais fait la réflexion d'accord alors
matthieu delormeau pourquoi vous n'êtes
pas choqué par la décision de
l'établissement
vous êtes d'accord avec les thèmes
absolument moi aussi je m'étais bien
souple et rosie je suis très pardon pour
l'uniforme jeu
idem pour filles ou garçons quand
j'étais à l'école une fille ne venait
pas non plus des cas rouge à lèvres ne
venait pas maquillée voilà on ne vous en
prend un
viendra alors on vient pas comme on veut
que ce soit religions que ce soit
maquillage quand on est à l'école voilà
il ya des choses à respecter
pourquoi effectivement demain moi je
vous donne un exemple tout bête dans ma
société cette société de production eh
bien je dis aux gens que quand l'été
arrive vous venez pas en débardeur
convenant aux chemises vous venez avec
une chemise
vous reprendrez s'étaient vendus
ailleurs en débardeur il faut pas des
pizzas c'est vrai qu'on est moins isolée
ont fait pas ce qu'on veut dans une
école oui mais alors oui j'aimerais
revenir quand même si en plus valérie
bénaïm vous êtes plutôt je sais pas du
tout oui voilà très stricte mais
simplement j'aimerais qu'on vienne sur
un mot qui moi m'a particulièrement
choquée de la part de l'établissement
s'est il faudrait que sept élèves
acceptent les codes normaux qu'est ce
que ça doit la cause est normal de gérer
ce que c'est que la normalité depuis
quand même c'est ça qui te fait mais
aussi alexis oui totalement parce que je
pense pas que fin le lycée comme vous
dites match que vous dites qu'il faut
respecter certaines choses et tout mais
si on se découvre pas en fait comment
pour plus tard mais moi je vais très
bien les suspects auraient donné s'il
était professeur au directeur pardon je
vous le dis à mon arme secrète pour ce
que vous voudrez quand vous aurez 18 ans
et vous serez grand ou attendre à
l'école et à l'école on apprend à le
respect les règles et l'ordre alors je
respecte quand je me maquille et que je
me crispe à des talents alors il y aura
deux minutes dominées toute une
clientèle difficile d'avoir une réponse
évidemment radicale mais moi je pense
que l'école c'est pas une tribune c'est
pas une scène c'est pas c'est pas le
théâtre mais pour cesser en fait c'est
le vivre ensemble chef c'est le respect
des valeurs c'est le respect des autres
moi ce qui me gêne c'est que votre 17
avec un collège oui moi je veux aussi à
la place d'une petite fille qui est en
sixième qui vous voit et qui n'a pas
peut-être les réponses à ça et qui ne
sait pas comment dire la meilleure
interview pour une fille de ceux qui ont
6e pardon elle peut se poser des
questions et qu'il a croisés que va les
résidus de croiser à la cantine très
vite tu ne te dis pas mon dieu qu'est ce
qui se passe à l'extérieur galabru un
maquillage qui échangent entre eux une
part de moi je termine juste simplement
mal il ne gêne pas le déroulé de la
classe ses camarades ça ne leur pose
aucun problème et sahnon hill n'entrave
pas le bon déroulement des cours
et voilà il il ne choque pas un parent
travaille bien c'est vraiment excitant
de première l inverse s'appuyant
première elle t'a dit il vient qu'hétéro
je ne vois pas pourquoi le match le
maquillage les talons devrait être
catégorisés le voilà oui donc toi tu
rêves de travailler dans la haute
couture c'est ce rsa et c'est vrai que
je vous le dis le maquillage pour hommes
c'est une tendance en plein boom en ce
moment de plus en plus d'hommes se
maquille moi je
laissez vous aller toutes les fractures
près après on va vous les pinces à
l'eurovision regardez la réaction du g8
n'est pas le bon chemin qui dit on
l'avait demandé le premier jour de tenue
et son maquillage et lui a mis sur les
réseaux qu'ils allaient le ferez bye bye
glissé en voulant dire qu'il préférait
lui quitté le lycée qui n'avait pas le
droit de se maquiller
il a même dit que par rapport à ce jeune
public on lui demande d'être alpes et
maquillée la direction assure qu alexis
ne sera pas sanctionné mais lui demande
d'être plus discret alors oui qui dit
moi je compte j'ai l'impression qu'on
n'a pas été tous dans les mêmes écoles
on a toujours eu au lycée ou au collage
le groupe de hippies le groupe devient
ainsi la crise mais du noir plein les
yeux
le groupe de e des footballeurs le
groupe des pom pom girls de ce que vous
voulez mais chacun a toujours été
différent et quand même m on se fait
agresser de temps en temps ou d'autres
agressent d'autres ça aide aussi à
prévenir de la vie des fois difficile
qu'on peut avoir
j'étais dans le groupe de pop girls me
suis dit moi je vous le dis avec les
gothiques qui avaient les yeux tout une
fille via des mini jupes à l'école voilà
et alors ils doivent alors maintenant je
suis désolé c'est pour la vie de merde
alors à tresser les cheveux rouges alors
quelqu'un qui a les cheveux et pour vous
tous en libye écoutez c'est lui moi même
s'il vous plaît est ce qu'on est très
hypocrite parce que lorsqu'on parle dit
certains clients scène bah je suis
désolé quand on digère ali tu dis c'est
pas le spectacle mais c'est pas un
déguisement et oui c'est sa vie c'est
son look nous même façon comme tu dis
qu'il avait dit qu'il aimait l'art tout
à l'heure oui bah c'est sa durée
allemand m'a pas dit où j'aimerais que
l'éducation nationale mette autant
d'énergie pour discriminer ce jeune
homme que pour lutter contre l'exclusion
scolaire lutter contre le harcèlement et
le plutôt qu'une très bien à toi et
bouge à dijon se dégager je pense que le
combat est ailleurs laissez nous
tranquilles il a eu en plus et dans le
monde soutient et je suis pas sûr que en
l'excluant qu'on va le protègerait une
petite question dans le coin d'interdits
alors pourquoi tant je vous pose la
question êtes vous allez dire que je
pose une question qu'on jamais pourquoi
non mais pourquoi on n'interdit pas le
maquillage pour les filiales ont alors
voilà il est interdit
max ou les ateliers ni de noter que dans
les établissements scolaires on demande
aux filles d'atténuer un peu leur
maquillage ou alors un maquillage
discret c'est le lieu de radio les
bagages
c'est un peu trop toi samaras et ça du
coup on va avoir un mec à l'entrée du
lycée
jérémy du bluff toi tu enlèves le blog
sert il est déjà beaucoup dit mimi
serment le césar de la démagogie depuis
le début de l'émission au printemps et
dont l'ex qu ils se mesureront veut
lutter contre l'exclusion ça n'a rien à
voir on va pas à l'école avec les
cheveux rouges une boucle d'oreille
d'emmener et maquillée comme une bagnole
données et ben non
les excès des années 20 en fait quand
vous déclarez quoiqu'avec mode hippie
j'arrive à peut-être il va être aidé par
alexis je vois pas pourquoi de passer de
17 ans hadji ce temps je vois pas en
quoi quand et majeur ça change quelque
chose n'était pas mineur que t'as pas le
droit de manquer enfin on est comme dans
une société où au jour d'aujourd'hui on
a le droit de faire quand même assez ce
qu'on veut c'est la liberté d'expression
c'est exactement ça tue à l'école tu à
l'école d'accord tous les matins à
l'école le moment on discute pas conçu
relève dont le voeu profession
professeur td quelque chose pourquoi tu
l'aidés pas va te faire [ __ ] chili ont
fait ça vous demande de vous asseoir et
de goûter à l'école c'est facile mais
qu'est ce que tu en penses toi moi ça me
choque pas voilà à partir du moment où
tu es bien dans ta peau moins cher quand
j'étais au lycée il y avait
effectivement des gothiques qui avait
les cheveux noirs du maquillage comme
dallas il y avait des filles qui avaient
les cheveux rouges et c'est à ce moment
là il faut mais c'est pas bien dans sa
peau si libyen en brasseurs ont soutien
gorge je suis bien
[Musique]
je trouve qu'il n'est pas outre en
sicile voir une jeune fille est arrivé
effectivement avec une jupe mini jeux
que ça choquera assez subjectif alors
voila j'aimerais savoir alexis que tu
vas faire alors tu vas arrêter le
maquillage
après tout ça continue mais ça me
renforce encore et comment ils vont
faire alors tu es maintenant
en fait j'ai du coup ça a été ça et le
lendemain on m'a dit que je pouvais
continuer à c'est vrai maintenant tu te
reproche de ne pas lui avoir tout part à
vau l'eau
mais en atténuant et d'un cadeau ah non
c'est pourquoi tu m'as qui efface je
fais pas beaucoup donc alexis je te
laisse donc train de me dire qu'on a
fait tout ce débat pour rien
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ça peut arriver à d'autres personnes
dans d'autres établissements enfin la
corse pas que je suis le seul cas qui ça
arrive est d'accord et donc maintenant
tu vas y aller comme ça voilà on va pas
compenser les téléspectateurs puisque
les chéneaux enfin ils ont mal fait le
décompte ski alpin même à décoller
voilà donc pas choqué à 60% en eau qui
sont plutôt comme vous ils ont été comme
vous il aurait pris la même décision
vous en majorité série qui votent en
majorité c'est les quinze ont leurs
effets sur les gens plus âgés